هنا إيفان، إن التغيير الجذري عندي يكمن في الإيمان،وأنا أؤمن بك،واؤمن أن لدي شيئا جنونيا
بالأخص هنا، هذا ما يجعلني أود أن أطلق العنان لأقول أني أود مساعدتك في رحلتك
سنستعرض الآن أفضل عشرين نصيحة مما
كل رائد أعمال
يحتاج
أن يسمعها
رقم
17 هي المفضلة عندي، وأنا أحب أن أعلم ما الأفضل بالنسبة لكم، كما تعودتم خلال مشاهدتكم هذه الأفلام
هنا، أن شيئا يجد صداه لديكم. ويسرني أن تتركوا لي تعليقاتكم في الأسفل،وتحيطون النصيحة المفضلة لديكم بأقواس كي تصبح مصدر
إلهام للآخرين. كما أنكم عندما تكتبونها هنا فإنها ستثبت في نفوسكم..حظ موفق!
أقول لفتياتي طوال الوقت أن عملك الحقيقي هو
أن تكتشفن
أين نقطة القوة لديكن
للعمل وفقها.
شخصيتك هي هباتك التي يجب أن تمنحها لتبرر السبب المنطقي
لوجودك هنا، إنها الأولوية الأولى التي يجب أن تعمل عليها: العمل على ذاتك وتنمية
نفسك،وأن تحافظ على كأسك ممتلئا دائما
لقد اعتدت أن أخاف من هذه الناحية، تعودت أن أخاف
خاصة من الناس الذين يقولون إنها تقول عن أنها نفسها أنها ممتلئة بذاتها
أو نحو ذلك، والآن أنا أعتنق هذه الفكرة
وأعتبره مدحا لي أن يقال أني ممتلئة بذاتي
لأنه فقط عندما تكون
عندما تكون عامرا في داخلك، تفيض كأسك على من حولك
لدي الكثير، لدي الكثير لأمنحه، ولدي الكثير لآخذه، وأنا لست خائفة
من تكريم نفسي. هل تعلمون
كم هي معجزة عندما تفكرون أنه شيء واحد، وأنا أحب شجاعتكم في ذلك
Willing to go in the Face of other People Telling you something that's Crazy and I know A lot of
Pretty Crazy People you Still stand out Where Does that come from or how
Do you think About Making a decision When Everyone tells you this is a crazy Idea Where
Do You get the internal strength to do that
Well First of All I'd say I actually Think I think I feel Feel fair quite Strongly
So it's not as, the I just have the absence of Fear I've I feel it quite Strongly
But There Are Times When something is important Enough you've leave it Enough that you, do you do it in Spite of the Fear
so Speaking of Important things like People Shouldn't Think Iii
Should if You Should Think, well I feel Fear About this and Therefore I shouldn't do it
It's normal to be to Feel fear like you'd have to Definitely something Mentally Wrong you Shouldn't Feel Fear
So you just Feel it and Let the importance of it drive you to do it Anyway yeah you know
Actually Something That Can be Helpful as Fatalism
Some degree
If You Just Think it's just Accept the Probabilities
Then That diminishes Fear
so
My Starting Spacex I thought the Odds of Success were, Less Than 10%
And i just Accepted that actually Probably I would Just lose Lose everything
But that Maybe Would Make some Progress if We could Just Move the ball Forward Even if we died Maybe
Some other Company Could Pick up the Baton and Move and Keep Moving it Forward
So that were Still do some good
Yeah Same with Tesla I thought the Odds of A clock Company Succeeding
Were extremely low I knew I was wired to be excited about Business how, or why?
I don't know but you know and There's Certain Guys They have the genetics to Jump out of the Gym right
Certain Guys You Know that you know When They Golf They have the Muscle Memory and and the Discipline you know dirt?
The Visca May not
Be the most Talented Guy in the
Nba but his Discipline and his Focused to do what's Necessary to be Successful
He's willing to do and Combine it With being seven feet Tall and being Skilled you know it Makes Him an Amazing Basketball Player so
It's understanding what your skill set Is
Finding The Right Place to use Those skills and then Going for it you know will that Make you
250 Grand it depends if You pick the right Industry But Whatever Industry you pick if you Outwork Everybody if You try
to be a little Smarter Than Everybody if You try, to be a better Salesperson and Everybody if You try
To be better Prepared Than Everybody you've got your best chance because if You, don't do it and Somebody else Does
Yeah I have the same Work
Like someone's Trying to Take it all away from you you know working
Actually Working Like someone's Spending 24 Hours Working 24
Hours to Take it all away from you and that's Kind of the way i look at it and
I remember
Asking my Dad - I want a new basketball Shoes Because I was A basketball
Junkie Back Then He's like
Well your Shoes Work if You Wanted new Bare Tennis Shoes you have to go out There and Get A Job and I'm like
Dad I'M 12 Years Old and it Just so happens he
Was playing Poker With his Buddies and One of his Buddies Just like?
Well I got a job for you I've Got These Garbage bags that We distribute you Can sell them Door-To-Door?
I'm like okay and it was when I was selling Them and Realized that I'd like to sell and that I could sell and
That I recognized That Selling was was About?
Providing The Service and Creating Value For People that I knew that I would Literally back Then I
Knew that I could Always Succeed i mean I remember I was?
16 I think When I
Started A stamp Company and Started Going to stamp Shows and Trade Shows and
Just working a little bit Harder Than other People and and
Trading Up from One Stamp to the next I remember one Time I started with a quarter and Bought a stamp and Left With $50
Thinking
Hey if I could do This I could do Anything and and it's not that everything Worked I failed a lot
But I never ever Felt like i I wouldn't
Be able to Work Hard Enough to Succeed a lot of People come to me they Say
Well I want to be an Entrepreneur and I go that's great what's your, Idea and They go, well I don't have one yet
and i Say
Well I think you Should go get A, job as a Busboy or something until you find something you're Really Passionate about Because
It's a lot of Work and I'm Convinced that about half
Of what separates the Successful Entrepreneurs from the non Successful ones is Pure
Perseverance it is so hard you pour so much your life
Into This Thing There Are such Rough moments in Time That most People give Up
I don't blame Them it's Really Tough and it Consumes your life i mean if You're if You've got a family and
You're in The Early Days of a Company it's I can't imagine how one Could do it I'm sure it's Been Done but
It's Rough I mean Because it's a pretty much a you know an 18 Hour day Job seven Days A week for a while so
Unless you have A lot of Passion About this you're Gonna not survive you're Gonna give it up
So you got to have an Idea of or a problem Or A
Wrong that You want to write that you're Passionate About
Otherwise
You're not going to have the perseverance to stick it Through and I think that's half the Battle right There
It's hard to remember how bad it was you know in
1980s With ibm Taking, over the World with the Pc With
Doss out There
It was it was Far Worse Than the Apple 2?
and They Tried to copy the apple 2 and They'd done a pretty Bad Job and you needed to know A lot and
So things, were Kind of Slipping Backwards and Macintosh was you?
Saw The 1984 Commercial you put that I hope you have that in your archives you know
Macintosh was Basically This?
This
Relatively Small Company you know in Cupertino California Taking on the Goliath Ibm and Saying Wait a minute your way is wrong
This Is not the way, We want Computers to go this Is not the Legacy
We want to leave this Is not what We want our Kids to be Learning This is Wrong and We are going to show you?
The Right way to do it and here it Is it's called Macintosh and this is so much Better than its Gonna beat you and
We are Gonna do it and
That's What Apple Stood for I
Realized That When You to have the level of Success
That I want to have it's difficult to spread it out and do
Multiple Things you know it's in Order to
To be World-Class and I'Ve Made a Decision I want, to be World-Class and it Just it takes Such A desperate
Obsessive Focus to to Excel on a Certain on the Level that I want to Make movies you know I was A?
Star Wars When I was Young I sat in The Movie Theater and Watched Star Wars and I just Couldn't believe?
That that Movie Made Me Feel like that just Floored and Just Stunned by the
Creativity and Just I'm realizing that in Order to
Move People in That way in order to touch People in that way you really got to Focus with all of your fiber and all
your Heart and all your Creativity
Failure is Part of life i mean
The Difference for me Though
Is i'm like a failure as a stepping stone to Success it's a speed bump I know I'm Gonna Fail
But it's not Failure if You learn Something and so Gosh I'Ve Made so many Mistakes I've Screwed so many Things out but
Every Time I do it just becomes it becomes A
Way for me to explain to someone Else what it Takes
You know it's like Here's what I've Done I think I have
The Ability to Influence People Because i talk About my Failures I talk about all the things that mess me up
But I show people that Didn't Let it stop Me and you don't need to stop you and I think I think That's Really the
Secret Matter and if Everything you touch was Successful first one got
A relate to people as much
Oh you'll be Late and also it's B total Bullsh and Everyone know it's Gold and
Also you'd be Bored Silly I mean Think About it if you just Said I want this to happen. I want this to happen
you Know People don't value it they
Don't fight for you know it's like you see Kids Sometimes in it you know your Parents will Say you're not Gonna value This if
You don't Work for it and your Kid going value Just give it to me
But it's True you know the things we've Worked the hardest for We Value the most so I think you know
The Purpose of the goal Is not getting it Anyway the Purpose of goal you know is what who you become?
Who you becomes Gonna Make you happier it's Gonna Make you sad so
I'm not looking for an Effortless Approach There's no such Thing as Fashion Belief that I can
Only Should Expect to Make Money and Things that I understand and When i say Understand I don't mean Understand
you Know
What the Product Does Or anything like that I mean Understand what the Economics of the Business are Likely to look at
Look like 10 Years from Now Or 20 Years from Now I know in general
What the economics will Say Wrigley Chewing gum will Look like 10 Years from now
The Internet isn't going to change the Way People Chew, gum it isn't going to change what you come They
Chew you know if you Own the Chewing gum Market in A big Way and you've got, Double mint Spearmint and Juicy Fruit
Those Brands will Be There 10 Years Analysis I can't Pinpoint Exactly
What the Numbers Are Gonna Look like on Wrigley but I'm not gonna Be way Off if I try to Look Forward on something like?
That That
Evaluating that Company is Within what I call my circle of Competence I understand
What They do I understand the Economics of it I understand the competitive aspects of the Business so?
Figuring out The Economic Consequences
Tv I
Think There's I don't know 20 25
Million Cents A year so in the united States I don't think There's one of them Made in The united States Anymore I mean you'd
Say TV Set Manufacturer What A wonderful Business site Everybody now Nobody had a TV in 1950
They're About 45 To 50
Everybody Has Multiple Sets now
Nobody Is in The united States and Made Any Real Money
Making the Cents if They're all out of Business you know the Magnavox is the Rca is all of Those Companies
Radio was The equipment of The 20 over 500 Companies Making Radios in the?
1920s again, I don't think There's A
u.s. Radio Manufacturer at the present Time
But Coca-cola you know I was at 1884 Jacobs Pharmacy or Whatever and Fellow Comes up with something a lot of
Copiers over the Years
But now You've Got a Company that is selling
Roughly 1.1 Billion Eight ounce Servings of its Product not all Cokes right and some Others
Daily Throughout the World
117 Years Later so Understanding
The Economic Characteristics of a Business Is Different Than Predicting the fact That an Industry Is going to do Wonderfully
So i look at the
Internet
Businesses Or Look at Tech messes i say this is a marvelous thing and I love to play Around on the Computer and
It Now I ordered my books from Amazon and all kinds of things but. I don't know who's Gonna win
Unless I know Who's gonna win I'm not interested in the Best Thing I'll just Play Around on the Computer and
Defining your Circle of Competence Is the most important aspect of investing
It's not how Important how large your circle is you, don't have to be an Expert on everything
But Knowing Where The Perimeter of that Circle of what you know?
on what you don't know Is and Staying Inside of it is all Important tom Watson seniors Started ibm
Said in His Book he Said I'm no genius I said but I'm smart in Spots and I stay Around Those Spots
And you know that is the key so if I understand A few Things and I stick in that Arena I'll do okay
And if I don't understand something but I get all excited About it because my Neighbors are Talking About stocks are Going up everything
They Start Fooling Around someplace Else Eventually I'll get Creamed and I should
That Whatever you do Somebody can do it better you have to bring your A-Game in Every single day
There's Nothing unique About Any One Individual What's unique is their Passion
Their Ability to Execute
to meet Targets and Exceed Them the Minute you lose that Ability
in Capitalism you're Gone
it's a fair trade
The Engine That Makes You Rich Can Take it all away from you
There Are no Guarantees I
Think That's Incredibly Important
Everyone has A problem with Time
But the day IS 24 Hours and We sleep six?
Now I know There's some out There that say, oh whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I need eight what I say to Sleep a little Faster
Because The Bottom line Is We have six Hours of Sleep?
24 Hours Are Available so if 18 Hours now Available to your Work
your Family your Hobbies and
Also to Learn something new Or to do something new Which Could Easily be that you want to learn a new language or?
that you want to Read and as A
New Year's Resolution I have to read a book every Week
Or where you say I'm Gonna Go and Reshape my party
So you're Gonna go and Take this hour out of your Schedule and Say I'm Gonna Train an Hour every day
So this Is for most People A
Huge Challenge but it is Totally Doable I can Tell them because the kind of things that I did
When i came to this Country i mean I went to school Almost Working in Construction I?
Was working out at five Hours a? Day? I was Taking acting classes from 8 O'clock at
Night To 12 Midnight I was Doing all of Those Things I?
Wanted To Make sure that out of the 24 Hours of the day that I don't waste one Single Hour
Those Hours, Were Too Precious and so they'll Just want to tell People
Don't Give Me This Thing I have A difficult Time of it the Time and I don't have Time for this now that you have
Time You Make The Time There IS an Advantage to being what I like to call now Hardcore
Hardcore I don't know Quite how to describe it it's a combination of Tenacious and Dedicated and Passionate and Committed
Something Like That Hardcore I learned About being Hardcore
From Math Concentrators at Harvard
I'm not going to ask Whether
We have Any math Concentrators here but I would Say That's Where I got kind of my Lesson I mean People Could Just go crazy
Focused Not it wasn't Just the people, were genius but Working and Working and Working and Working
You Know, I'd sit in my room working on a problem set after Three, Hours I'm a little Ad D. I just Couldn't Take it
The Most Hardcore People Could Just Power Through Anything and
The Advantage of Being That Tenacious and Dedicated and Committed I
Claim it helped Us at microsoft it's Fundamental at microsoft but I learned it here at
Harvard I went to red Box about Two Months ago
Went to go give me A red Box i told See I was getting A red Box?
And he Joking you Still getting Ready Bob I'm like yeah. I was wrong A red Box?
He's like Netflix you ain't no netflix I'm like no I wanna Watch TV oh I saw One Watch no movie I'm on a small
Computer A
Little Small Computer put it on TV and so I can put my stuff on my TV
I'm gonna Buy one No auxiliary Cord all running Through my crib
Like that he's like not a smart TV. Bro I'm Hearing hey. I ain't got, no smart Tv I
Need you to hear what I just Said I got Bread and I got the same TV I bought when I moved out why?
Cuz I could put on and that Joke Would come on Y'all laughs you like why, Would you do a TV like that
Cuz I remember Back in the day when used to get the Hangar With your luminal Foil and drop that Joker
Oh and this Cloudy Cloudy and you trying to, do what you got to, do so what I got is Ways?
We used to have to this Old School you had to turn to get the Stage Station -
Then You do Tube seven
Right and that Joint went Off at night Y'all Team you don't even go on our TV
Like he Left the whole Egg, on you see by the dawn's Early light that Yogi begone I
Could Just go and Catch me I'll get a brand new One but the Reason why
I don't do it is because of a healthy sense of Stairs in These grades You get too, much you got too
Much you get everything you lose your bite I can't Afford to leave my fight ever Gonna be Without you're doing what i'm Doing
and if They do it better than me my eating Whatever Lifestyle
My wife is retired at 45. Cuz
She's got A mess she Cannot go back to Work I cannot Let You beat me so I'm not gonna go five Three Four Columns
Scarcity you Cannot Have everything you see it's not
Healthy There's Desert There's a part of lack that Make you hungry
There's A part of Eating Peanut Butter and Jelly Sandwiches That Make you Deeper Than the dude That's Eating Five-Star Meal
Let me Tell you something man I promise me Or everything I love
If I could do my life all over again I promise you I would i'm glad my dad I
swear you i'm glad I lived in A Band of dealers I
Swear to you i'm glad I got my Job I love the Castaway smarter
I'm looking at grown Me Ain't where they want to be in Life and no part of they like and They Waking up at eight
or, nine O'clock in The Mill I'm like Bro what you smoked in I
Thought you
Was a Christian you want no no Drugs no Drugs are you invested in you
do you Care about you so what you need to transition from Which Show entitled Self what you need to transition from Is
Friends and Fun you need to stop Having it and Till you get to where you want to be in Life
you need to stop Having all that fun and you need to just start Making Up in your mind Just Start Saying you Broke
Just Start Saying it Because you Probably are Thrilled Even if You got some Money you Probably got your Parents Stuff it
Probably Don't belong to you which means you Didn't earn it Is what I'm Talking About
so if You have something that you did not earn you have to stop telling Yourself that you have
Something Look You got to hear what I'm Telling you I'm Trying to help you I
Only Take Pictures of Clothes That Belong to me I
Don't put my Boy Shoes on and then Take a pic in it like Their Minds
Know and what I'm Trying to tell you is you are broke but you
Don't realize you broke Because you're Living Somebody Else's life and if You're Living Somebody Else's life
What you Should be able to do Is say I am Grateful that this Person is trying to set me Up for Greatness
But I won't Fake it like it's my life all I'm Saying to you is when you Act like you got something that you Really
Don't then you don't have the drive that it Takes to be Successful
I find that levels of Success in Almost Any Industry or Area Correlate To a Person asking great Questions
In some Cases They Seem absurd in fact the hallmarking way of great Questions Is that sound Completely Ridiculous
So someone might ask like peter Thiel why Can't you achieve youR 10 year Goals in the next six Months
There's A thought Exercise that's like that's that's A good Question to answer for Yourself
and These Types of Questions Come up Surprisingly often
With With very very Impressive
Folks Whether it's in Business Military Entertainment or Otherwise and the way you can get better at Questions Is by
Studying interviews in Part so i studied Larry King I studied Charlie Rose i studied Terry Gross I studied that
The go Down the List i studied tony Robbins who Does in Person
One-On-One Interventions at his Events in Front of ten Thousand Five Thousand People and He's Just genius With
How he uses Questions to like Pattern Interrupt and
Grab someone's Attention and Divert Them in A more productive productive Direction
Now why Is that Relevant Relevant Because?
Thinking Is the Process of Asking Questions
You're Asking Yourself Questions then you're answering Them in your own head so if You get Better at asking other People
Questions You get Better at asking Yourself Questions which means you are A
you're Improving your Thought Performance and
Level of Thinking so it looks like you
Always Go out of your Comfort Zone Right Coming on to an Island that was Completely deserted
no Fresh Water you don't even Have the Money to Buy it and
And now you're Sleeping on A tent on the Beach trying to Figure out how to get
Fresh Water Here you do that often You did it With the Airline i mean I was Just Somebody that?
Experienced The Bad Experience of Traveling on Airlines I was Actually
Trying to get to the Bvi the british Virgin Islands One Day from Puerto Rico and the Same Lovely Lady
Was waiting for Me and I've Been Away for Three Weeks and?
American Airlines Bumped The Flight and
and I went to the back of the Airport I had a plane I
Had A black board I wrote
Virgin Airlines
One-Way
$29 to the VV
I went Around all the People have Been Bumped and I filled my first Plane and
And that got me Thinking you know that Airlines do bump People they
Don't Care About you or me Particularly in the air and so, we
saw them Rang up
Boeing and Said You Have Any Second and seven for seven
Okay i mean it
Was literally that You Just sat in The Airport and so I'm Starting an Airline right Now we Cannot Frustrate it?
Exactly and I think most most of the Best
الأفكار الريادية تنبثق من الإحباط،وأعتقد أنك لو كنت
محبطا تجاه شيء ما؛ فإن أفضل طريقة لفرزه هو الانطلاق والبدء بتنفيذه، وستجد نفسك في خضم المشروع.
We know from our Past Experiences That Big Things Start Small?
You know the biggest Oak Starts from an Acorn and You've Got to recognize you want to do Anything new
It got to be Willing to Let that Acorn Grow
Into a little Sapling and Then Finally Into a small Tree and Maybe one day it'll be A
Big Business on its Own and in Fact That's one of the
Mottos for One of your Initiatives and forgive my my Pronunciation of the latin but
Greta Team for Oct what does that mean to you, well it means
Step by Step Ferociously and it's the Motto for blue Origin
and
Basically you Can't skip Steps you have to put one Foot in Front of the other Things Take Time
You There are no Shortcuts and
but but you want to do Those Steps with you know Passion and Ferocity
When i said the Business cos, it's so difficult to be a Small Business
Owner in China it took me Five Pounds to Bond
$500 as Stupid
No Chance and
It is it Is and I have no any Idea About how to run a Business and I when I go to register Company Called
Internet The Register Officer Said no There's
No Such A word Into the new Dictionary okay Register and Internet so i said you have to register Another Name Zing
It wasn't what's The Name is A computer Consulting Firm and I have no Idea about what is Computed
so my first Company's Pounds of Hope
Because Computer Consulting Firm
It was Tough was Not Know Anything but Enough Technology Without Knowing Anything but A Computer in the past of Fifteen Years?
Been Working I call Myself like A blind man Riding on the back of the Black Tigers
Those Esper's Riding Horses They all fell
We survived Because We Worried by the Future?
We believe The Future We change Ourselves?
We never?
Completely Honest you
Went to Harvard and you Dropped out Have you ever Thought how your life Could be Better off if You had Gotten Your Harvard, degree
Well I i'm A weird drop out Because I take college Courses all the Time I love
Learning Company Courses and Things so I love being a student and
There Were Smart People
And you know They fed You and They gave you these, nice grades that Made you Feel smart
So i i feel it was Unfortunate that I didn't get to stay There but
I don't think I missed Any Knowledge because you know Whatever I needed to learn I would I was still in A learning Mode so?
Stripping That all back to Starve your Career a man with a dream
You Know Training in The Gym, day in doubt if Somebody Said to you
You'll Have or you'll be as Successful as you are now what have you had Said Back Then I
Believe You that's what I would have said
Because I did Believe I believed in I had very Few People who told me that I had a small
Small Small
Group of People That Would Tell me something like that
Order Than that it was Just me Telling Myself
Yeah so if Someone Came Up to me and told me that all the Way back then, i'd Say
You're Damn right I got a uh
Yeah i started working at this Video Store was pretty Much what you're Talking about Around that Time and
And it was great at first Because I'd always hated day Jobs and Stuff and so I got a day Job and it Ended up
Being Pretty Good but Mentally I was There for Five Years at a Certain point it was our?
Narcotic all right I didn't have to Keep Pursuing my dreams Because you know it's not what I want to do but it's
Sort of Kind of Close and if I didn't have an Artist soul Burning in me I could have Made Myself happy
With that I could if I if I didn't have an Artist soul Burning to get out I could Have
You Know Walked Backwards A couple Steps and Just done That and Would have been A
Fulfilling To Anybody Else it Would Have been A fulfilling life it. Wouldn't Been for me Because
I wouldn't know and I would have had something to Say that I didn't get a chance to Say
but it did put me to sleep for a While and
and
I've Always Just Thought I mean What Really got It got everything Kind of Truly Going for me You Could point out A lot of
Different Things but The Bottom line Is the fact that I realized that the even The Group of People I hung around With
They, were all great great great Fellas and great gals
but
You Know. I was Easy for me to think that? I was doing a lot because?
I was doing more to try to move Myself Forward Than they were
But you know that's not yeah yeah okay, i'm A big Fish in a puddle
So what all right They're not doing Anything
So yeah, I'm Doing more Than them
But I
Realize That
Actually I need to get my
Ass out to Hollywood and meet other People who are you know like in my
Category Or
Or working a little higher and and I should be the Weakest Link in My Chain
That I have and That'll Make me be Stronger, or Make Me run Faster I mean like an Analogy I've Always used Is
Alright if You run the Hundred yard dash
With a people that can't run
As fast as you yeah you'll win hands down you know that but if You run With
People much Faster than you all right yeah you might Come in Last Every Single Time but your Time will be Better
Because They're Making You run all the faster They're Making making you dig Down Just a little bit
More it doesn't Matter that you and your Time is Faster and that's what I knew I had to do I had to get out
of Loserville and Throw Myself
Into a place Where like this is what they do for a living one Night Chris Had gone to bed I
Had Been Struggling Struggling Struggling, We still had all the Same Problems I?
We stalled A lien on the House Still Facing Bankruptcy Still Fighting like Crazy I was Still Unemployed?
He Still they Still haven't Figured out like the solution yet for the Business
And I was about to turn off the TV and There on the the TV there was this Rocket Launching and I thought
Oh my gosh!
I am Gonna launch Myself out of bed like A
Rocket Ship like Nasa Right here Had Launched me out of that bed and I'm Gonna Move so fast that I don't think
Hmm i'm Gonna Beat my brain
Now Here's A really Interesting Point I
Talk A Lot About your instincts and inner Wisdom and
We can get Into This a little bit Later but A lot of us talk about the fact that you have a gut Feeling
But what all this Research that I've Done for the book and and all the Speaking that I do what I've Discovered that's?
Fascinating is Actually when you set goals when you have an Intention on something that you want to change about your life?
your Brain Helps you what it does is it Opens Up a checklist and
Then your Brain Goes to Work Trying to remind you yeah of that Intention that you set and it's Really
Important To Develop The Skill and I Say that word Purposefully the skill of
Knowing How to hear that inner Wisdom and That Intention Kicking in and
Leaning Into it Quickly so for me my brain Saying that's it right There
Move As fast as a rocket mel I
Wanted To Change my life and I think Most people that are Miserable
Or that are that Are Really like Dying to be great and Dying to have more, We want to Change?
We want to live A better life, We want to Create more for our Families? We want to be Happier the the Desire Is There
Again it's about how
Do You go from Knowledge to Actions so the first Thing in The Story that's Important is realizing that the answer was in Me and
My mind was telling Me Pay Attention I?
Could Have, also Been The Bourbon
Anyway the next Morning The alarm Goes Off and I
Pretended Nasa
Was there iT's a stupidest Story I literally went 5 4 3 2 1 I counted out Loud and then I stood up and
I'll Never Forget Standing There in my bedroom it
Was dark it was Cold it was Winter in Boston and?
for The first Time in 3 Months I had Beaten my habit of hitting the Snooze Button I
Couldn't believe it and I thought Wait a minute
Counting Backwards that Is the Dumbest Thing I've Ever Heard in my entire Life
Well the next Morning I used it again and it Worked
The Next Morning I used it again and it Worked the next Morning I used it again and it Worked and
Then I started to notice Something Really Interesting
There Were moments all day Long
All day long Just like That Five-Second Moment in bed
Where I new Knowledge what I should, do?
And if I Didn't move Within five Seconds
My Brain Would Step in and Talk me out of it
Every Human Being Has A five-Second Window might even Be Shorter for you
You Have about a five Second Window in Which you Can move from Idea to Action before your brain Kicks Into full gear and
Sabotages Any Change in Behavior
Because Remember your Brain is wired to stop you from doing things that are Uncomfortable or Uncertain or scary
It's your Job to learn how to move from those Ideas that Could Change everything
Into Acting on is There a time to bail out on a Project
Though I mean when I don't know that's not in my Vocabulary yeah Look I?
Have a i have an unfair advantage you know. I went to war A?
War i'm alive Because other Guys died for me when you see stuff like that you know how Can I quit
Most Guys I just wimps Pussies
Cowards They don't have it
So they Shouldn't get A
Job so Thank you Guys so much for Watching I hope you enjoyed I love to know which of the twenty
Had The biggest Impact for you meant the most to you
you're Gonna
Immediately Take Some Kind of Action in your life or your business please Share your thoughts leave me Down the Comments Below I'm Really looking
Forward To Hearing from you Thank you Guys Again for Watching I believe in you I hope you Continue to believe in Yourself and Whatever
Your One Word is much Love see you soon?